SMIL alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings a peace how are you guys doing
now for those who have been watching the
Deen show for quite some time you know
we're going on over 10 years 500 plus
episodes with the main mission of
claiming many of the misconceptions the
false fallacies about Islam educating
people on this beautiful way of life the
fastest growing way of life in the world
yet most misunderstood delivering the
purpose of life we should want to know
our purpose right we've been created for
what this party and play know there is a
purpose and many have questions and we
had a 1-800 number that people can call
now we have and we've been collaborating
with dr. Sabeel from gain pieces he's
going to share some wonderful story
how's it been now since the new
president president's taking office have
the calls fluctuated gone up have they
gotten down some stories to share with
us how are you alhamdulillah salaam
aleikum wa rahmatullah wa alaikum son
may peace and blessings of allah be upon
you and to all the listeners and the
Watchers out there dr. bierd there was a
sister a medical doctor you were sharing
with me a very just inspiring story
about her kind of having some health
issues she thought she was gonna die she
saw the 1-800 number inviting people to
call tell us where tell us about the
stories very touching story okay al
hamdulillah so about three months ago
you received a call on the game pieces
hotline 800 662 so this number is out
there on the brochures and the
billboards TV radio media so many
thousands of people call so far
alhamdulillah and after the shows I
usually put this number out I say people
if you have any questions call the
number before you leave a rude comment
or something call us yes call us and if
you have any questions give us a call if
you need a copy of the Quran give us a
call if you want to become a Muslim give
us a call right under Ella no force your
choice but we are there so about three
months ago we got a call from this lady
from the sister
and she said that she saw this telephone
number and the reason she is calling is
that she wants to become a Muslim just
like that just like that and we were you
know so it's not as surprising to us
because literally thousands of people
have called and they have embraced Islam
on the telephone so each time a person
calls we ask them the question in a
welcome to Islam how did you hear about
us and tell us your background you know
how what made you interested in Islam
but you usually someone like her who's
called she's done her research she's
been usually this is this is the end
this is like okay the decision has been
made if they want to embrace it but have
you found that most people who call and
say I want to take Shahada or I want to
become a Muslim they've done their their
research yes almost all the time they
have done the research
but even then before anyone takes a
Shahada or embraces Islam we go over the
six beliefs and the five pillars just to
make sure that we are getting giving
them authentic information yeah you know
it so happened that they may watch a
video or they may interact with a Muslim
or maybe read a book and sometimes
people become emotional and they call
and they take the Shahada which is good
but before we give them the Shahada we
make sure that they understand the
fundamentals of Islam so alhamdulillah
v'n this lady when this sister she
called we asked her the question you
know what made you interested tell us
about your background so she said that
she has studied Islam for some time
actually for a long time and she's a
medical doctor and she was having some
problems health problems severe problems
so she went to the ER so she was calling
from the hospital by the way but the
reason she was calling that time and not
waiting until she goes home is because
she was saying what if she dies in the
hospital what if she does not have time
she wants to embrace the message of
Islam when she is alive even it be from
the hospital from the ER bed
alhamdulillah and she took Shahada
brother Eddie lying on the bed in the ER
she proclaimed la ilaha illallah
muhammadur rasulullah there is no other
God besides one God Allah in
Hamid Allah Allah Allah is the messenger
and the slave servant of Allah I mean
that's that's the reality we're all
gonna die and I think life and all its
and and the things entertaining us that
kind of has us not thinking about the
reality of death but she felt something
coming on she's but she's still alive to
today she made it not only she's alive
but she's an active muslima mm-hmm now
she's helping other new Muslims
alhamdulillah she's part of our whatsapp
forum by the way and if anyone you know
is a new person if they say that you
know I need help and so in so situation
she's almost always the very first
person to welcome them to Islam and to
step out to help them out which form is
Angela
it's a whatsapp forum group yeah for the
new Muslims it's a nationwide group that
we have so they can interact they can
help each other yeah through again peace
so she's on there she's helping people
now mashallah she's aren't there she's
helping people she became a mentor of
the new Muslims even though she is a new
new Muslim Muslim ah herself okay so she
went through investigating Islam looking
at all the evidence that Aslam provides
and some people need extra push
so that ER visit whatever was going on
in her life hopefully we can get on the
program as she can tell us more the
details of her story and and and what
what was affecting her but it was that
bad that she felt like she I can die
here right you know it's a wake-up call
you know our Creator gives us so many
opportunities all throughout our lives
the challenges themselves can be a
science may be the 800 number that the
sea could be assigned maybe when they
watch the Dean show and look at the
truth of Islam could be a sign so the
science of Allah subhana Allah
opportunities are all over the place if
a person looks at the opportunity grabs
the opportunity gives us a call or sedin
show alhamdulillah they are the chosen
and the blessed ones so I hope and pray
that those who are watching the show
were not yet Muslims give us a call 866
- Islam we are here to help out you know
24/7 give us a call if you need to study
more we can converse with you and
a question that you have inshallah we
can we can answer that could that be
about Sharia law the misconception the
media is spewing out there could be the
concept of jihad you know it's been
twisted right and left multiple
marriages a prophet muhammad sallallahu
wasallam or quote encode the violence by
some muslims and he called any doubt any
concern that you may have give us a call
we can let you know what the Quran
teaches about these noble concepts how
was that how was the noble life of
prophet muhammad sallallaahu seldom
right so God has given allah has given
these opportunities let's grab the
opportunities and we pray that may Allah
guide you and all of us I think that's
that's the higher route to take many
people will as soon as there's a video
or something to do with Islam many
people we know that was it Time magazine
back in the early 70s they printed an
article talking about the over what was
a 5060 thousand books anti Islam books
that were printed you heard about this
yes in the Western countries and I
believe it's its lose Time magazine they
say it's a higher number by the way hey
yeah it was no that don't know I'm sorry
over a span of a hundred fifty years yes
they were calculating that over fifty
thousand books were written against
Islam so that's over a span of 150
thousand one hundred fifty years yeah
did you hear this one
yes yes so now somehow you know this is
the information that people are getting
on Islam now a person ends up hearing
something you know twisted about it the
nobler route is to pick up the phone and
call before someone you know have you
ever read taking a chance you know time
out and you read some of the comments
that people have made really just nasty
vile you know I invite these people
someone who might be watching this and
someone is just usually they're
projecting something of hate that's
inside it they're just not happy with
themselves usually a person just when
you're at peace you have peace you live
in peace you're happy you don't
personify this usually you know and you
you take take a more noble route
even those person who are bitter and
angry I mean this could be the key mate
to eradicate that that disease in the
heart right and I think that's the it
takes some courage to do that so pick up
the phone call 1 800 662 Islam ask any
questions you're saying it doesn't
matter what caused make the connection
and have a conversation you know one
more story comes to my mind regarding
people sometimes when they are
brainwashed by the media or by some
friends of theirs so 26th of August we
had a open house at the Islamic Center
of Romeoville about an hour from here
after the presentation and the social
activities and the tour of the Masjid I
approached a non-muslim sister a
non-muslim lady neighbor and I asked her
ok what made you interested to come to
the mosque you know and how did you
enjoy the open house and she said she
said that she knows ABEO my friend
warned me never to go and meet the
Muslims because they may kidnap you so
her friends tell her this yes yeah and
then she said you know my friend said if
you're going to go to the mosque open
house do not eat their food because it
may be poisoned Wow right I had then
with a big smile he said you know sabi
I'm still alive nobody kidnapped me and
I'm still you know have it and the food
delicious so when people attack Islam
some sincere people they became more
curious and alhamdulillah they leave
with positive experience in fact on that
open house we had many many copies of
the Quran every single one of them ran
out and we have to scramble to get more
copies because that was that much demand
by our neighbors people think now since
with the new President and Islamophobia
on the rise I I was looking at some of
the numbers where he was an all-time
high all-time high that it's ever been
about on the amount of mustards that
have been attacked vandalized bombed I
mean like never before so you know
people's obviously through many corrupt
and evil politicians who are also
capitalizing off of this fear and false
propaganda you would think now how is it
because this is like on the scene the
calls that are coming in to this number
the requests to get more crowns how is
it is it it is if you say business if
you look at it from a from a business
person Islamic law or higher gear
alhamdulillah the business of saving
souls their ego I think that's a better
a better way of packaging that message
but they're just given an example how
people were you know if they had if this
was something up actual product but this
is something more valuable than any of
that on the 8th of November when mr.
Trump when he when he became victorious
when it comes to the electoral college
or so many Muslims we were not fearful
by the way but we were overly cautious
what is going to happen to the Muslim
Ummah in the West what is going to
happen to the world I mean obviously we
had trust in Allah subhana Allah right
so when it comes to the Islamophobia the
hate attacks and the burning down of the
Mossad geez there's a reality and
fortunate reality of Islamophobia but
when it comes to Dawa or the business of
Dawa as we would say how is the business
going saving of souls we never had
whether Eddie as good of a year when it
comes to Dawa as this year the year 2017
and the year is not over yet
I mean people and then closeted to know
about Islam look at this we had more
calls from people asking about Islam
this year then we had any year in the
last twenty five years this year yeah
this year 2017 more calls yes and we
heard that Dawa telephone line since
1993 mm-hmm we had more people
requesting copies of the Quran this year
than any year in the past can you
imagine that wow we had more positive
coverage by the media this year than all
the media coverage --is since the last
25 years how about this one here how
about this one
that's amazing how about this one here
right we had more mustard open houses
this year in the USA that all the open
houses in the last 25 years combined say
that against more open houses where
people are requesting to come visit a
mosque or you're having an open house at
the mosques sending invitations and
people come for themselves to learn to
see to meet Muslims more than combined a
combination of all the years prior to
this year yes hundred more people have
been attending these open houses yes so
we had more open houses and also more
people attending the open houses mm-hmm
you know in fact when we had early this
year at MCC Masjid right over Chicago
Masjid a thousand people came
alhamdulillah we had that the ICN Masjid
open house close to a thousand actually
1200 people came at the Masjid al Qaeda
we had open house 500 people came in the
Bolingbrook Masjid the ma B Masjid about
400 people came right literally hundreds
of people are coming so more people are
coming more open houses that any other
year in the last 25 years combined and
there's the blessings allah subhana
allah has given to us but look at this
one here mm-hmm
this statistic al hamdulillah by the
guidance of Allah subhana Allah more
people embraced Islam this year than any
year in the last 25 years through the
gain peace and the mossad ease so so one
such of one such person by the way are
you ready for one more story so this
person he called and we had many call
takers call associates so I was the one
from the LA who took the call and this
person he said you know can I have a
free copy of the Quran I said ok fine
brother what is your name your your your
address and we will send one to you then
I became curious you know WA so he was
calling from Philadelphia form from
Philadelphia
you know John what made you interested
to read the Quran this is his story he
said that many of my friends they went
to Afghanistan and Iraq to fight the
Muslims because we became really angry
after nine-one-one mm-hmm then he said
that I was not able to go because I had
some obligation my family my business
over here but I took the mission to
fight Muslims and Islam by reading their
Quran by by examining their ideology and
I want to destroy their ideology so he
studied for the last about 17 years
since 9/11 and finally he called and he
said I have a few more questions for you
and after his questions were answered
better ready that person used to be
really aggressive islamaphobe against
islam and muslims on the telephone the
more that he read the Quran the more
that he examined tawheed of against
Trinity and all of their his heart
melted on the telephone this person he
recited
la ilaha illallah muhammadur rasulullah
this is obviously when someone wants to
accept Islam to say that declaration and
they make that there's nothing worthy of
worship except the creator of the
heavens and the earth and Arabic Allah
and that Muhammad just like Jesus Moses
Abraham and all the preceding messengers
they were sent by God
they weren't gods they weren't semi
God's demigods they were callers of God
messengers calling people to worship
only God exact not just fits that fits
that's like the piece I've been people
say like that's what I've been looking
for because many people because of all
of the esoteric all of the mystical
strange things I've been associated with
man-made counterfeit religions they kind
of throw them all in the same bunch and
just get turned off of religion so
there's a big lesson for our audience
out there may that be our fellow
brothers and sisters and humanity right
give Islam a chance read the Quran
examine the noble life of Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him because on
the day of judgment when you stand in
front of the Creator he is going to ask
you the question I have given you the
opportunities they were wonderful shows
like Deen show gain peace telephone
number free copy of the Quran they were
offering they were
running the open houses in in the mas
close to you why didn't you grab the
opportunity and that would be too late
for them to come back and grab those
opportunities now he's at time my dear
brothers my dear sisters of humanity
life is very short it is unpredictable
people end up in the hospital and
they're making the calls
right yeah that's up he's not gonna ask
you about the Conor McGregor Floyd
Mayweather fight Canelo triple G a golf
tour that those are all the part the
parts of the entertainment and it's
interesting that when someone is like a
in a position of life or death like she
was she started to reflect started to
think I need to get serious she accepted
Islam be someone is now confined let's
say in jail sadly you know there's many
people who end up in jail they come in
as non-muslims not yet Muslims and you
see that why is Islam the fastest
growing religion not only outside of
jail but also in jail the statistics
prove that Islam is in the prison system
it's that these people they weren't
Muslim you know some obviously might you
know who not practicing Islam they might
you know end up there but people who had
nothing to do with Islam they go in now
what I wanted to say be it now they're
confined meaning now they got time to
open up the books so many distractions
in life right so much things
entertaining us 600 satellite channels
you know the clubs on the weekends pubs
on the weekdays you know it's so many
things people just they don't have a
chance to just sit and reflect and think
City big building but now you know about
that number and in the prisons now a
person gets locked down now they can
open up and read and they choose Islam
because it has the evidence it provides
the facts not the fiction the purpose in
life and people are accepting it in the
in the prison system actually you know
again peace has a department called
prison Dawa we have dedicated resources
and personnel we are actually
advertising in the prison magazines for
the inmates and the prison magazines for
administrators showing them that we have
this service if your inmates or that
many administrators would like to call
they can give us a call and we can send
them free copy of the Quran and the
literature because they have a lot of
time I'll handle Laurie yeah you know
one more story right are you ready for
this one this one is really interesting
story we had more visits to the Masjid
by the schools and colleges and the
churches right this year that any year
that I can think about and here is the
story regarding this so there is this
teacher who used to bring her kids for
many many years you know each time the
senior class social studies humanities
class and this teacher she heard the
message of Islam so many times correct
Allah suppose not Allah is given her the
opportunity hamdullah
two months ago the teacher from
Naperville alhamdulillah she accepted
Islam the teacher wow she's been
bringing in groups and she's been
hearing the presentation she's been
hearing the introduction to a sign
finally she accepted Islam she was
thinking perhaps for you know the
presentations so she comes to the MSI
Masjid and other massages by the way
right so there are three important
things that we need to discuss one would
be they may be curious our viewers may
be curious you know what what is the
most important aspect within Islam or
what what is the number one reason
people are accepting Islam right is it
the concept of oneness of God is it the
noble life of Muhammad peace be upon him
is it the Quran guidance is it the hijab
morality modesty let's say there's a
question that will come to their mind
the thousands of people what is the
number one reason what do you think it
is what I I I mean I think it's the the
concept of God you know the the pure
monotheism the direct and simple message
the purpose of life easy to digest easy
to implement that is the answer by the
ready yeah it was my price
right a good deal for you maybe I'll
give you the best in this love and
generative here those in the hair after
you your family and the Muslim Muhammad
I mean when we ask them the question of
our fellow Americans and people of
different nations when they call in the
embraced Islam of their own choice that
what made you interested the number one
thing that made you interested when they
look into Islam and almost always more
than 60% of the time they say it is the
oneness of God absolute monotheism
compared to the multiple persons in
Trinity compared to the idol worship
compared to giving divinity to creation
how Islam separates absolute monotheism
absolute oneness of God hamdulillah it
touches here it is rational no
mysterious dogmas and it touches here
oneness of God the same message that
ibrahim alaih-is-salaam Prophet Abraham
Moses and Jesus and Ishmael and Isaac
and Muhammad peace be upon of them they
proclaimed number one reason why second
important point the viewers may be
curious Peschel ii the muslim viewers
you know better submit what happens
after the thousands of people who
convert to islam what do you guys do
what happens after the Shahada right
it's an important question what happens
from the day that they embrace Islam
first and foremost we give them a
welcome to Islam package alhamdulillah
it's a gift from the Muslim community to
welcome them come join the Muslim nation
and the Muslim Ummah alhamdulillah you
are one of us now you have a 1.7 billion
family members second we appoint trained
mentors so we have mentorship training
that we provide with the massages and
the Dawa centers and the different
groups number three we have classes for
this new Muslim brothers and sisters
alhamdulillah both online classes and
in-house classes so if any Masjid would
like to obtain these resources we can
help them insha'Allah number four we
have many social activities right
because Islam is not just about
education and education it's about
healthy halal permissible fun activities
for the families and for the kids and
then we have conferences you know just
we have the igner is
Maris care conferences we have
conferences for our revered brothers and
sisters in Islam so one such conference
which is coming up is the first of
October 2018 Sunday right from 10:00
a.m. up until about 6:00 p.m.
insha'Allah
at the water Ford banquet so if anyone
goes to gain peace calm forward-slash
conference or call us at the telephone
number and you would be part of that
conference it is for networking
socializing educating it's a good fun
education educational activities for our
new Muslim brothers and sisters in Islam
inshallah we're almost out of time just
a couple more points what's the couple
more questions what's the number one
misconception so we you tell us what was
the number one thing that attracts
people to Islam and and obviously people
now they know that Islam simply means to
submit to peacefully submit your will to
the crater that I was in Irv and that's
how you get peace in life in the heart
and and so what is it that people have a
misconception about what's the number
one thing when they call the question
that they have nowadays in 2017 yeah the
number one misconception people have is
about Sharia Sharia law is this a mm-hmm
so Sharia law people have this a notion
that Sharia law is something harsh it is
going to come to America it is going to
force everyone to become Muslim it is
going to kill all the non-believers a
lot of this misconception that the media
sometimes puing they think that is what
Islam or Sharia law is all about in a
nutshell
Sharia law is God's guidance that God
has given so humanity can live in
justice morality equality and peace with
all hmm
but Sharia law given to Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him for Humanity is not
the very first time God's guidance or
Sharia law came to humanity you know
when we in fact look at the Ten
Commandments in the Old Testament Exodus
chapter 20 verse number 3 Deuteronomy
chapter 5 verse number 6 the Ten
Commandments
see was the Sharia law guidance given by
God to prophet Moses and his people take
only one God do not worship anyone
besides him do not make any graven
images respect your parents be good to
your neighbors do not lie do not cheat
right we said that was the Sharia law
given to prophet Moses and his people
but what comes do you think brother le
comes to your mind when somebody says
Sharia law or what do you think comes to
the mind of our fellow Americans when
they hear about Sharia law I mean
totally the opposite of what's supposed
to come to the mind I mean it just shows
the power of the media and the brain you
know the the distortions that have been
perpetuated out there that the false the
lies half-truths and it's just it
reminds me of when somebody looks into
this they smake the connection I just
recently had a investigative journalist
and he's also an academic terrorism
expert he was a he called he calls
himself he he called himself before he
was a Muslim bigot he was trying to
blame Islam for everything right and
this is what many people are doing
nowadays the politicians right the
scapegoat they need a scapegoat but it's
interesting CJ wheeler men had a mounted
show and he was now he was talking about
the genocide that's happening in in in
Myanmar right against our rowing and
Muslims he is sitting there being on a
voice for the oppressed Muslims right
and he's saying that this is this is
nonsense
right the facts the data right that he
went down and investigated he wanted to
see what motivated people because they
try to link and say okay it's Islam
that's motivating people but when he
went down this rabbit hole and he looked
into he said this is this is just
fiction it's not true right yeah it's
not true it's a it's and this is an
academic right yes and many other
academics who have who have taken the
time but most people don't take the time
that's the thing they just what's been
passed down they just you know repeat
like parrots so it's important lesson
for our fellow Americans and for the
Muslims and for all of us God has given
us a mind and an ability and bless
things of knowledge and experience and
we have to use it and not blindly
believe and blindly follow yeah
so again when it comes to Sharia law
it's important for us to know it is not
just about a punishment system you know
I give this example all the time right
suppose if aliens if they are aliens out
there if they come on and come to earth
and ask me the question
you know Sabeel what is the Constitution
all about if I tell them that the
Constitution punishes people by lethal
injection by electrocution and by
hanging if there's all I say and then
they leave am i doing justice to the US
Constitution no I'm not right
why because I'm only touching upon the
punishment system in the US and ignoring
the breadth and the beauty of the
Constitution in the same way within the
breadth and beauty of the Sharia
guidance that God has given to humanity
less than 0.5% deals with the punishment
system and every society needs to have
checks and balances punishment system
there's the reason we have the law
enforcement the police force the Armed
Forces the Homeland Security is it not
in the same way with proper checks and
balances Islam also has the punishment
system but the rest of the Sharia law
deals with a unity of humanity chapter
49 verse number 13 that how Allah has
created one male and one female and made
us into nations and tribes in people so
we get to know each other there's part
of the Sharia law part of the Sharia law
is to fight racism anyways and forms it
exists out there right Muhammad peace be
upon him he said that a Arab is no
superior to a non Arab in an Arab is no
superior to an Arab a white is not
superior to a black and black is not
superior to a white all of your children
of Adam and Adam was made from dust
equality of humanity all the races is
part of the Sharia law it's part of the
Sharia law to take care of our neighbors
our world our neighborhoods you know
Muhammad peace be upon him he said that
you're not a full believer if you eat
you're full and if your neighbors are
hungry it's part of the Sharia law to
take care of the minorities in a Muslim
country
right protecting the minorities the way
Muhammad SAW Allah Allah's Salam and he
moved from Makkah to Madinah how he
protected the Jewish people from them
being prayed by the the superpowers of
the time the Sharia law is God's
guidance but you know just like some
Christians have taken verses out of
context from their Bible or the Jewish
people have taken passages out of their
Bible and have caused the Crusades
oppression of the Palestinians the
Inquisition the slave traders and the
colonial powers they have used the Bible
their ideology for their own agenda some
misguided Muslims using the word Sharia
law or jihad they have oppressed that
women they have taken the rights of the
of the minorities they are forcefully
converting some some non-muslims if they
are doing it they're going against the
clear-cut teachings of the Sharia law
that gives the protection to the
minorities autonomy freedom or for
practicing their faith so again a lesson
for all of us my dear you know better
Elian for all of us is that do not
blindly believe what people are saying
and following and actions of misguided
people if you want to know what Islam is
give us a call we can give you a free
copy of the Quran have your mind open
come to the open houses converse with
Muslims then you will find the truth in
sha allah often so you got nothing to
lose but so much so much to gain by
making that connection take the higher
route it's easy to be a keyboard troll
and say Vaio you know profanities and
hurtful words but go ahead and call
before you do that be brave enough to
make the call 1 800 662 Islam ask your
questions have a dialogue and make your
decision from there and then call right
now they can't call right now right now
you can call 1 800 662
thank you for being Wars Doctor Sabeel
inshallah we'll have you back again and
thank you guys for sitting through
another episode of the D show subscribe
if you haven't
and call call us let's make the
connection ask us your questions and
let's see what happens from there thank
you so much for tuning in we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
Islamic
you